[Music]
that's how we did it in the 90s son
can't catch my breath man really should
i try mouth stuff what is this a tinder
date get off of me oh [ __ ]
mr dante i need an ambulance at the
quick stop saved my life man i wish i
had a life worth saving what are you
talking about sit around and watch the
same movies over and over i always
thought you could have made a cool movie
you're right i'm living on borrowed time
no more watching movies i'm gonna make a
movie
what's the movie gonna be about it's
about him working here meta everything
in the script is something either me or
someone i know said i'm not even
supposed to be here today
maybe jane silent bob could be
characters kay and silent barbara liked
c-3po and r2d2 they've been here since
the first movie which was the last time
they were cool but they've been with the
franchise so long they still give them
cameos and put them on the lunch boxes
snoopy
please
i believe in you
you put in that stuff you used to say
about the death star contractors
get sued by disney no way
take off your pants
uh what the hell is this i added a scene
where you get shot i'm not letting you
kill me off in the third act what if
there's a sequel a sequel what am i a
hack
i think it needs more weed
[Music]
you